he's my hyperbola it actually made give
us an equation with actual numbers in it
which is nice x squared over 4 minus y
squared is equal to 1 and there's some
point x1y1 so let's let's pick on a
point if you got feet that's gonna be
like that x1 y1 okay
and the tangent at that point so it
would look like something like this I
guess is my tangent change it it meets
the asymptotes X let's put X up there
and why capital one okay sure that the
product of the length measures shouldn't
leave my origin you owe X which is up
here that's that's okay the product that
times this there's a y show that
required to prove that oh x times y
sorry equals five okay so if we want to
work out oh x times y I suppose it makes
sense that we want to know what X is and
what Y is and then we can actually
multiply them together you might think
oh maybe there's a simpler way to do it
but actually the quantity here is not to
sorry that the the equation mu R Us is
not so difficult
by the way that for their in that five
that's not a coincidence okay so let's
try to work this out now we actually
know what the equation of a tangent like
this is we actually did it in that
previous question
it's a X x1 on a squared now we don't
have to say a square here because we
actually know the number it's a it's for
isn't it so I could say X x1 for and
then I could say minus y y1 over 1 I
guess because my B squared here is 1 so
that's that's it
that's equal to 1 that's the equation of
the tangent okay
now it's just gonna be a little bit
easier if we just get rid of that
fraction so
just multiply through by four that's
that's the equation of the tangent okay
yeah what am I going to do with that
well I can work out the corner to
capital X and capital y by solving this
tangent right I want to solve it with y
equals B over a times X which will give
me capital X and then I also want to
solve it with - be on a X which will
give me this some point of intersection
down here okay so can we give it a girl
how would I go about doing this I guess
would help if I could well which where
would you start if I've got this here
and this here
I guess Y is already a subject here so
I'll stick it in so that will give me X
X 1 minus 4 times B over a X Y 1 which
equals it before and what do I want
the only variable I actually have here
is X that'll give me the x-coordinate of
capital X that's a bit confusing I know
but they gave us the name so whatever
all they need to do is really factorize
out what's going on here right so oh and
by the way that's been silly being a I
actually know what being a are don't I
from up here B is going to be 2 and from
over here what a sorry what I say a is
gonna be 2 and B is going to be 1
because they actually give us those
values so I can say instead of B over a
I can actually just say 1/2 okay all
right so what I want I might as well
simplify a little bit X X 1 minus 4
times 1/2 is 2 2 X Y 1 that's all equal
to 4 and I'll take out that common
factor of X which gives me X 1 minus 2 y
1 equals 4 so now I basically have my
coordinates or my coordinate for X
that'll be 4 divided by X
- you won't okay now you can go ahead
and you can rehearse it for this but you
can actually imagine because the only
difference between Tamir for this and
this is that negative sign right what
are you going to get at the end down
here is going to be still for over X 1 +
2 y 1 because that sign is going to come
along here and it's going to be divided
through and that's what you'll get ok
now you can do the ad you can sub that
back in to the equations and you'll get
Y coordinates as well and I think this
is how everything yeah you'll get for
capital X you'll have we already worked
out this corner - y1 and when you sub
that back in to get the Y value you'll
get 2 over X 1 minus 2 y 1 because don't
forget it passes through x over 2 1/2 x
so you'd expect the y coordinate to be
just half of the x coordinate and you
get the same thing for capital y which
is 4 over x 1 + and then this guy's
because negative B over a there's a
different asymptote so that's why
okay no I want the distance from o to
that and then o to this and then I want
the product okay now there are no fancy
tricks to get the distance formula okay
it's just going to be distance Oh X is
equal to and then you do your square
root blow up okay now it's a bit boring
okay here's where you boil down to
you'll get the square root of 2000
revoir
and then this denominator because it
appears twice you get it gets squared so
to my one okay so you can you can handle
the algebra for that but you notice I
think in the square root and I have a
square on the bottom so I'm gonna get
the square root of 20 all over X 1 minus
2y 1 in a similar way when you work out
why you're still going to get a square
root of 20
okay and it's all divided by the
different denominator that we had if you
remember these kinds of denominators up
here okay now they want the product Oh
x times y okay well no problem on the
numerator you got square root 20 square
root 20 you get 20 okay and then on the
denominator you have this now just look
at it for a second and think now you
recognize this this is just difference
of squares right so you can factorize
that which gives you X 1 squared minus 4
y 1 squared but we were not expecting
this we were expecting 5 okay that's
what they told us to expect now being
that everything else hopefully the
numbers are not like kind of thing if
all the numbers are right if we did in
fact get 20 on the top then you would
expect the denominator to be equal to 4
well the question is well where did they
pull out for frog and remember I told
you the actual numbers they gave us were
significant right so x1 y1 don't forget
it's on the hyperbola right it's on the
hyperbola that means it actually
satisfies this equation
yeah all right so I I can actually say
look x1 squared on 4 minus y1 squared
that should be equal to 1 because it's
all bhai it satisfies that equation now
if I just multiply through by 4 you get
X 1 squared minus 4 y 1 squared that's
equal to 4 right apparently because X 1
y 1 is on the hyperbola but that left
hand side there that there is exactly
what my new my denominator is there
right so I can say as X 1 Y 1 is on the
hyperbola that's what I would say okay
that means that this is a nominator is
equal to 2 4 okay which is fine
okay now admittedly that's you'd be
pretty hard for us to see that you'd be
like are you serious how was I supposed
to look like that that's part of why
they gave you the 5 so the way you get
to this point you're like no no no
something something must be missing this
has to be connected to what I know
somehow it's just a question of what
okay
so that's how you solved the question